I DON’T KNOW WHERE IT IS.
AINSLEY: FIND IT.
PETE: WITH CONTROL OF BOTH THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE, DEMOCRATS
NOW HAVE THE CHANCE TO FAST
TRACK PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN’S
PLANS FOR THE ECONOMY,
HEALTHCARE, AND MORE BUT WITH
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION SET TO
TAKE POWER NEXT WEEK NO REPRIEVE
OF LOCKDOWNS NEXT GUEST WARNS
THE ICEBERG OF COMMUNISM GOYA
FOODS PRESIDENT AND CEO ROBERT
UNANUE JOINS US NOW.
MR. UNANUE, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> STEVE, YOU HIT THE NAME SO
GREAT.
CORRECTLY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD BEING WITH YOU THIS
MORNING.
STEVE: YOU HAVE BEEN ON A COUPLE
TIMES I HAVE FIGURED IT OUT.
SO, ROBERT, WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
EXACTLY THE ICEBERG OF COMMUNISM
IS AHEAD?
>> WE WERE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
WE HAVE BECOME DIVIDED.
WE HAVE STATES THAT HAVE
SOCIALIST TENDENCIES AND STATES
THAT HAVE DEMOCRATIC ON
CAPITALIST.
ARE WILL WILL DOING FANTASTIC.
ONE OF THE GREATEST ECONOMIES IN
THE WORLD AND ALONG COMES
CORONAVIRUS AND THE PERFECT
STORM OF DIVISION QUITE HONESTLY
HATRED OF THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
FOLLOWERS AND AN ECONOMY THAT,
YOU KNOW, A DIVISION THAT EXISTS
IN THE COUNTRY.
STEVE: AND NOBODY KNOWS MORE
ABOUT THE DIVISION THAN YOU
BECAUSE YOU WERE CALLED --
DURING THE PANDEMIC, AND YOUR
COMPANY HAS DONATED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF FOOD BANKS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
YOU WERE CALLED TO THE WHITE
HOUSE CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE.
YOU WENT.
THEN PEOPLE ON THE POLITICAL
LEFT TRIED TO CANCEL YOU WITH
ESSENTIALLY A BOYCOTT BUT THEN
IT TURNED AROUND PEOPLE WERE
SUPPORTING YOU WITH A BUY-COTT
AND I UNDERSTAND BOY A FOODS HAS
JUST FINISHED YOUR BIGGEST, MOST
SUCCESSFUL YEAR EVER.
>> YES.
>> THE PROBLEM IS POLITICAL YEAR
THEY WEAPONIZED CORONAVIRUS
UNFORTUNATELY TO SHUT DOWN THIS
ECONOMY.
THE WORST THING WE CAN DO IS
SHUT DOWN OUR ECONOMY, KILL OUR
SPIRIT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE WE
NEED A REASON TO GET UP IN THE
MORNING, GOD, FAMILY, WORK.
AND TAKE AWAY OUR SPIRITS.
TAKING AWAY OUR ABILITY TO WORK.
THEY ESSENTIALLY, YOU KNOW,
DECLARED MARTIAL LAW, I BELIEVE,
IN THIS COUNTRY, SHUTTING
EVERYTHING DOWN.
IT’S THE WORST THING WE COULD
HAVE DONE JUST FOR POLITICAL
GAIN.
I THINK IT’S CRIMINAL.
I THINK IT’S IMMORAL, SHUT DOWN
THIS ECONOMY FOR THIS ARE
BASICALLY POLITICAL REASONS.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE’RE ONE NATION
UNDER GOD.
WE’RE NOT ONE NATION UNDER
TWITTER.
WE’RE NOT ONE NATION, YOU KNOW,
UNDER BIG MEDIA OR UNDER CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE’RE TRYING TO HAVE MEDIA BIG
TECH, CONTROL OUR LIVES.
THE GOVERNMENT CONTROL OUR
LIVES.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO NOT
MOVE AWAY FROM GOD.
WE NEED TO MOVE CLOSER TO GOD.
THEY WANT TO CANCEL GOD.
THEY WANT TO CANCEL OUR SPEECH.
THEY WANT TO CANCEL OUR CULTURE,
OUR HISTORY.
OUR LIBERTY.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL US.
THE FEW CONTROLLING THE MANY.
LIKE A BUNCH OF SHEEP.
YOU KNOW, NONE OF THESE PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT US, YOU KNOW WE CAN’T
MOVE AWAY FROM GOD WE NEED TO
BUILD NOT HATE AND DESTROY.
SOME OF US WANT TO BE ONE NATION
INDIVISIBLE.
YOU CAN’T BE INDIVISIBLE WITHOUT
GOD.
WE HAVE TO PRAY AND HAVE HOPE
AND MOVE CLOSER TO GOD.
OTHERWISE, IT’S NOT A PRETTY
PICTURE.
STEVE: YOU ARE A CEO I HAVE GOT
TO ASK YOU JOE BIDEN UNVEILED
CLOSE TO $2 TRILLION PLAN TO
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY AND
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE AS WELL.
ABOUT HALF OF IT IS GOING TO GO
TO DIRECT PAYMENTS TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE HURTING ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND INVARIABLY OTHER
PEOPLE WILL GET THE MONEY AS
WELL.
BUT, ALSO, IT’S GOING TO BAIL --
WE HAVE HEARD FROM MICHAEL WALTZ
THE CONGRESSMAN FROM FLORIDA,
IT’S ESSENTIALLY A BLUE STATE
BAILOUT.
IT’S ALSO ESSENTIALLY A BIG
GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER.
BUT THEN AGAIN, THAT SHOULD NOT
SURPRISE US BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR A
LONG TIME AND ELECTIONS HAVE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> IT’S TYPICAL POLITICS TO
THROW MONEY AT A PROBLEM.
$600 CHECK, A $1,200, $1,400
CHECK IS -- PEOPLE ARE OUT OF
WORK FOR A YEAR.
THAT’S $2,000 COMBINED.
THAT DOESN’T DO ANYTHING AND
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS WHERE DID
ALL THAT MONEY GO?
WE HAVE GOT TO GET BACK TO WORK.
WE CAN’T SHUT DOWN.
WE NEED TO WORK.
WE NEED TO GET UP IN THE MORNING
AND PRAISE GOD, WORK, OUR
FAMILY, THAT’S WHAT WE NEED TO
DO.
WE NEED TO GET BACK TO WORK.
OTHERWISE, YOU KNOW, SO MUCH
BOLOGNA THAT WE’RE JUST THROWING
MONEY AT THIS.
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, IT’S
RIDICULOUS.
LET THE POLITICIANS DO THEIR
STUFF, BUT, LET US GET BACK TO
WORK.
PLEASE.
STEVE: THERE YOU GO, SOMETHING
TO THINK ABOUT ON THIS WEEKEND.
HE IS THE CEO OF GOYA FOODS,
ROBERT UNANUE, SIR, THANK YOU